we've just seen the collapse of FTX the
highest profile and certainly one of the
biggest cryptocurrency platforms what do
you think that tells us about the state
of cryptocurrency
so I think what it tells you is there's
a lot of activity that's developed over
the last uh 10 years on the trading and
sale of crypto assets assets without any
intrinsic value so they're incredibly
volatile and all of that has grown up
outside of outside of Regulation and
what we saw I think in FTX and there are
investigations going on and I've got no
knowledge of what's actually happening
inside that but what we seem to have
seen is that a number of activities
which in the regulated financial sector
would have had certain protections and
regulations around them happened in an
unregulated sector and then we saw
things like clients money appears to
have gone missing conflicts of interest
appear to have happened between
different different operations
transparency audit and accounting all of
the perhaps boring things that happen in
the normal financial sector didn't
really happen for that set of activities
and as a result I think a lot of people
have lost a lot of money you're
considering regulation of this sector at
the moment is there regulation you
foresee that would have protected I
should say um investing in crypto assets
like Bitcoin and the like is a very
speculative activity their value can go
up but it can go down over the last year
we've seen that value go down uh go down
very quickly so I think if people invest
in that sort of thing they need to know
what they're doing they need to know
what it is they're actually buying this
is not a safe investment that you might
put your money in uh for a length of
time it's it's in effect in my view a
gamble but we allow people to bet if you
then want to to to to to to get involved
in that you should have the ability to
do that in a place that is regulated in
the same way that if you if you gamble
in a casino they're regulated you should
have the full information on the tin as
to uh as to what you're doing there will
always be people who will want to
operate perhaps on overseas
uh exchanges or exchanges on the
internet that are not in regulation but
I think for the majority of people if
they do want to be involved in
speculation in this area it's not
something I would do but if they do want
to do that then for Consumer Protection
Market Integrity they should have a
place to do that where they get the
protection that they would get in a
similar activity in the UK and I think
that that is important
there's an argument isn't there that if
you compared it to gambling the question
I was going to ask you is it more akin
to gambling than investing but there is
an argument that given the
it's highly speculative it's there's no
intrinsic value it's actually got no
place in the financially regulated
system and it should be left outside do
you not as clean up the view you share
so so
um we allow people to buy very
speculative things in the financial
system and some assets uh are completely
safe
um but some assets their value can go up
and down and some are linked to
a link to uh clear intrinsic value
others are more speculative this is
really at the extreme end because as you
say there is nothing backing this up all
it is worth it's a piece of computer
code that you own that can't be
replicated and that's worth what the
next person will pay you so this is
really at the extreme end of that the
reason why I think the the idea that why
don't we just leave this outside and and
it can people can lose money and and uh
and make money but if it burns it burns
I think that some people have put it
there's three reasons for that one the
reason I just cave which is there are
people who want to engage in that
activity provided they do that with
their eyes wide open in a place that is
safe it is not full of money laundering
or illicit finance and it's not loaded
against them then we should provide them
at least with the opportunity to do that
two this crypto trading of crypto assets
was not big enough to destabilize the
financial system but it was starting to
develop links with the financial system
I don't know how that will develop but
we had Banks and
um
investment funds and others who wanted
to invest in it and I think we should
think about regulation before it becomes
integrated with the financial system and
before we could have a potential
systemic problem and the last reason to
to maybe to regulate it is that there
are Technologies here which could and I
stress could be of use of real use in
the normal Financial system more
efficient ways of doing things
potentially more resilient ways of doing
things that hasn't been proven in the
crypto world but if we can provide a
regulatory space where people can see if
they can develop products using this we
might be able to get the benefit of some
of those Technologies if I could just
take those briefly perhaps in turn on
the first but providing a safe space is
there regulation that you can foresee
that would provide protection
in a UK regulator for a UK crypto
trading exchange so uh the uh the
treasury has said they're going to
consult uh next year on what regulations
should be in place to govern things like
um the offer the promotion the the uh
what you say about the uh the product
that you're offering uh around there are
already some regulation to cover money
laundering
and some of the illicit finance
activities uh but also can the exchanges
be regulated so that you get the
protection you would normally get on an
exchange can we deal with
um uh protection of client funds Market
Integrity there'll be a consultation on
that and these things could be brought
within the regulatory perimeter if they
meet those regulations to give people
the protection as I said they would get
in an equivalent activity
given
the volatility we saw what happened in
2008 with derivatives that not enough
people understood is there a danger in
bringing it into the main if you
regulate people will be more likely to
invest and there's a risk of infecting
the system again with something that
people don't understand and has the
power to really undermine Financial
stability uh well I think it depends on
two things one it depends on what the it
is
so we talk about crypto and most people
think of Bitcoin but that's just one use
for some of these Technologies around
encryption tokenization smart
algorithmic contracts so there could be
uses that we want to bring in actually
to the financial system where where we
could see benefits from that side but
the second point I think is
um we would need to regulate to ensure
that we get the same level of protection
the same level of resilience as we would
have normally now before uh before the
crypto winter of last year and the FTX
implosion this year I think a number of
uh established Financial players
investment funds Banks as we're thinking
of getting involved offering Services
custody Market making and the like and
we need to make sure that if that is to
happen
than the standards uh the the standards
are correct so
um
I I don't think it will be possible to
say this can be just kept outside of the
financial system it's too dangerous I
think it is difficult but possible to
say let us let us bring it in where and
when we think we can manage the risk to
the standards we're used to and make it
safe and the third point there is the
potential of this technology just give
us a snapshot of what the people have
promised the Earth with blockchain but
what do you see is the potential okay so
make clear this is not just about
blockchain and it's not just about
distributed Ledger there's as you often
see with technological change it's a
number of different Technologies coming
together I could give you a very real
world example for those people who
bought a house uh when you buy a house
you have to transfer the funds from your
bank to your solicitor the solicitor
keeps to the funds the old solicitor on
the other side gets the title and when
the lease go in the the conditions of
the contract are ready the two
solicitors agree and exchange the title
to the house for the money and you need
those two trusted intermediaries to do
that because you clearly those two
things have to happen simultaneously if
you can find a way to make a digital
tokenized as it said representation of
the title of the house and a tokenized
representation of the money and you can
create a contract that can't be
interfered with that says when certain
conditions are met those two things will
happen automatically then we take out if
you like a whole area of delay activity
cost in the chain and you could think
about that for share trading you could
think about that for for trading of
bonds these these so-called smart
contracts in which the um the thing
being sold and the money which is buying
it uh or the swap of two different
things is automated in a way that it
can't be interfered with and can happen
instantaneously could take out a lot of
delay a lot of cost potentially And I
stress potentially because these things
have not been tried at scale within a
regulated framework potentially could
take out some of the risks in the system
the government says it wants to be a hub
for this kind of stuff and wants to
attract this kind of investment is it a
um
do we
do we need the regulation for that to be
a safe ambition
I think you need the regulation for two
reasons one for it to be a a safe
Foundation I think the government very
much agrees with that there's a bill
going through Parliament now that will
give the bank of England uh powers to
regulate stable coins when they're used
uh to make payments
and we're developing the regulatory
regime there but I think it's another
thing as well that actually innovators
people who are developing new systems
want to know what is the regulatory
framework I need to work within how do I
design my technology my product the
thing I'm trying to offer to people in
such a way that it will meet regulation
so you know and I think if we're going
to get
uh sustainable Innovation things that
are really useful and that can can last
the developers have to know what the
regulatory framework is so they can
develop within it so we're going to
people who what's just happened with FTX
may have confirmed Prejudice they
already will give they already hold
about crypto they might say the UK is
crazy to be going near this stuff this
should be this is this is the wild west
you know the bank of England's been here
for 300 odd years
shouldn't be our business so we have to
be very clear what we're talking about
if we're talking about using these
crypto Technologies
to create basically crypto assets that
have nothing behind them that are very
volatile change in value I don't think
there's ever going to be a sustainable
sort of financial activity around that
there are some people who want to invest
or gamble on them and as I said before
people should be allowed to do that but
I don't think there's a sustainable
Financial system built around things
that can lose half their value in a day
or or increase half their value if we're
talking about creating the regulation in
which people can see whether they can
develop services that have benefit using
those Technologies to the real economy
um and and and the services have benefit
because of the technology and the
business model not because they're
outside regulation and it's easier for
them to operate then I think there is a
real benefit for the UK in terms of the
technology and just the services we get
as as uh as households and firms you're
also thinking here about Central Bank
digital currency why does the Bank of
England need a digital currency so we
issue money to the public you're
probably carrying some in your wallet in
the form of of cash banknotes uh and
they're like we don't issue currency
that can be used on the internet for
internet shopping or many of the places
around the bank of England here no
longer accept cash so cash physical cash
will always be made available by the
bank as long as people want it and many
people depend on it but it's not fully
usable in the way we live uh in the way
we live now so the question for the bank
of England is that as the way we change
our society changes as we live our lives
more digitally as they say should we
continue to provide money to the public
which is usable across a range of
transactions why should the Central Bank
provide money to the public well by
providing cash to ensure that all the
other forms of money that exist and most
people don't realize when they use their
bank account they're not actually using
Bank of England money they're using
their deposit at Barclays which is a
mention One bank it's their claim on an
individual Bank
um the fact that everybody is has the
ability to ask for Bank of England money
on demand every time you go to an ATM
ties that whole system together it means
that all of the money that circulates in
the economy has the same value and the
same robustness and if now we're going
to get new players using new
technologies and the world is going to
become more digital I think it may be
important for the bank to issue its own
digital currency to tie all the other
currencies all the other types of money
in the UK together and to be clear the
bank would still stand behind that
there'd be the equivalent there'd be a
digital so it would be a digital
equivalent of the I promise to pay the
bearer which in the end underpins
confidence
in money uh in uh in the UK so whenever
you want you can turn the money you hold
in a bank uh into
basically Bank of England money backed
by the state with that promise I promise
to pay the bearer and we want to ensure
that as physical cash becomes less
usable in many parts of the economy
perhaps we need to offer something
digitally to provide that underpinning
and is there a world in which that
digital currency replace its cash
um we'll see how Society develops I
think physical cash will be around for a
long time many people have prefer to use
it not everybody is you know some of us
adopt technology very early some of us
adopt technology kind of very late do
you think cash will see us out so uh
cash will certainly see me out
um but
um uh you if for many of the
transactions that you want to make you
can't use cash and that's becoming
increasingly true we saw it during the
pandemic when a number of us all of us
switched to uh internet Commerce and the
like question is should we provide
alongside cash
a digital Bank of England banknote if I
could put it that way that can be used
electronically and that can be built
into some of those new services that
might be developed with the new
technologies we know that crypto arose
out of in the the wake of the financial
crisis and it's real Advocates who said
it was a direct response to remove the
middle remove institutions like this
digitized trust
do you think about whether there's a
possibility that the the rise of this
highly speculative
um
asset
is actually a product of the cheap money
era that followed and perhaps
its shrinking now might be a consequence
of the end of that
so I think the motivation of the
original developers was as you say a
number of motivations some was to avoid
the state and to avoid government
some was to provide cross-border means
of payment it actually isn't you the
Bitcoins aren't used uh in um in payment
very much because to be useful for
payment money has to keep its value if
between the time it leaves me and the
time it leaves it gets to you it loses
half its value it's not going to be very
useful in a transaction and certainly
it's become a much more speculative
asset and when we went through covid and
then some of the a crises that we've had
since Russian invasion of Ukraine we
haven't seen uh Bitcoin and these
cryptocurrencies go up in value some
people say they're the new gold you know
they are the safest thing they've gone
the other way they've been the most
volatile thing they've lost the most
value uh in that sense so do they have a
future as a safer form of money than
that produced by kind of central banks
and the financial system no I don't
think so the opposite